ils étaient plus de 16 mille coureurs à
s'élancer dans la 8ème go sport running
premier départ dès 9 heures du matin
pour les plus aguerris un 15 km dans des
conditions presque idéales et un cadre
royal le parc du château de versailles
voilà pour ce royal on a accès inde est
une des parties du jardin qui était
jusque là inaccessibles c'est les
jardins de la ferme de marie antoinette
donc je pense que les coureurs vont
vraiment prendre beaucoup de plaisir le
cadre à autour du château c'est quand
même assez assez sympa ça change des
autres courses où c'est beaucoup
plusieurs vins là on a un côté fort et
un côté au parquet un côté château les
paysages sont sublimes par contre
c'était dur j'ai imaginé que ce serait
du plat mais non c'est des faux plats ça
monte ça descend conservant la course
aussi un peu plus ludique un peu dur
pour moi aujourd'hui
il a été mon livre je lui ai servi des
bons débuts après les parties pensais
qu'il allait me lâcher mais finalement
c'est moi qui les achètent
au total quatre courses étaient proposés
objectifs de l'événement qui se veut
familial le rendre accessible à tous les
niveaux c'est le sport accessible à tous
à tous les niveaux à tous les âges
et c'est une course conviviale aussi au
delà de ça les gens se déguise voilà les
gens ont le sourire
il n'y a pas forcément de recherche de
performance on est là pour se faire
plaisir et et c'est ma vision du sport
aujourd'hui et l'ambiance était bon
enfant au départ de la course des
princesses 8 km de parcours que les
participants pouvaient accomplir déguisé
non on est pas déguiser on est naturel
s'est naturellement montré à ma femme
que je peux courir aussi en robe
longévité les talons mais
ça sera pour l'année prochaine
[Musique]